yo le comento que esté en una zona rural
estés vacas gallinas cerdos alrededor yo
estoy escondido en una aldea donde
en la casa que era la casa de los
abuelos de mi esposa
y donde ellos se refugiaron durante la
segunda guerra entonces esto es la
ucrania profunda esto no es una ciudad
donde donde yo estoy actualmente
yo estaba en luz en la luz y ahí fue de
donde salimos el primer día cuando hubo
los tres bombardeos
gonzález nos habló también de la
dicotomía sobre si quedarse allí o
intentar salir de ucrania
pues estoy
en cruz y jada porque
queríamos estar aquí en esta aldea en la
que estamos con mi familia por un tiempo
para ver cómo se desarrollaba la
situación pero digamos hoy en la tarde
bombardearon una ciudad más hacia el
oeste hacia donde estamos nosotros en
una ciudad que no tiene nada que ver
poner la supuesta operación militar que
vladimir putin anunció entonces yo creo
que esto va
a tomar una connotación mucho más seria
aunque habíamos querido quedarnos un
poco más tiempo para ver que estamos
pensando en salir en esta semana buscar
cuál es la frontera más cercana que esté
menos colapsada para intentar salir el
problema es que para nosotros con los
niños es mucho más complicado por último
le preguntamos sobre si tiene intención
de regresar a colombia esta fue su
respuesta
pues la
cancillería está ofreciendo un vuelo de
repatriación que sale de varsovia
supuestamente lo 11 pero no está
confirmado aún por qué
a ver le digo éramos más o menos 200
colombianos en ucrania de los cuales
sólo quedamos alrededor de 20 personas
y el resto ya ha salido y con los
contactos que tengo de gente que ya ha
salido son muy pocos los que quieren
regresar a colombia
entonces y esta es como la encrucijada
que yo tengo porque yo salí hace 12 años
de colombia debido a la situación
socioeconómica y política
no encontré oportunidades de trabajo y
por eso decidí salir no y ahora en esta
situación pues yo no tendría
por decirlo a donde llegaría a hacer
hacer que llegaría a cruzarme de brazos
a engrosar las listas y los las cifras
de desempleo nuevamente entonces para mí
no es como
que digan ni un huevo a colombia es la
salvación pues en este momento no lo es
para mí